I wanted to I don't know have a little
pre Valentine's Day Valentine's Day a
little bit alright so today we are
working from the house like I said
before we are having a new roofing being
installed and the workers have turned on
the radio and it's driving me nuts
I don't know that GoPro can pick it up
this building that we're in the the
infrastructure the the walls are so thin
and like just the vibrations rattle
throughout the entire complex the
hammering is bad the drilling whatever
the sawing is then the unloading of
materials is bad but it's not as
constant as the horatio Caine turned on
radios driving me nuts
you actually hear it better down here
mm-hmm
oh hi Michael is helping us out with
some work stuff yeah thank you hear it
better down here maybe I bet you can you
still here in the office and the radio
is really rumbly you have a nice base on
that radio I don't know if you guys hear
it it's driving me nuts so what are you
doing it I'm trying to do some jakey new
stuff too but I can't hear myself think
[Music]
true noise cancelling headphones or that
- oh you own - am I just being sensitive
though I I know I am I get kind of like
like really sensitive to like noise and
stuff like neighbors have their base on
I'm like it drives me nuts but it
doesn't see in the drive TIFF or Isaac
like crazy the way it drives me crazy
oh really listen this one's really
annoying I think the reason why it's
driving me crazy it's because it's
unnecessary like they do not need to be
playing the radio while they're working
on our roof like that just that's that's
a an optional thing that they have
decided to use which i think is very
considerate thank you inconsiderate very
inconsiderate because they are working
above people that live here and so why
are you gonna be creating even more
noise that is just unnecessary so I'm
like come on man it's not even music
either it's like talk radio yeah why why
are you doing this that's the part
that's upsetting me it's the fact that
it's an inconsiderate usually yeah I
mean noises don't bother me like yeah
like if it's the next-door neighbor and
he's playing some music and it's like
the bass is kind of AC I'm like he's in
his own home he's enjoying his space
it's fine it doesn't it doesn't bug me
that as much as if books you like for
you it's like I can't think rage and
you're just like how could you like do
this like how could you do this to my
ears yeah how could you be having so
much fun in your own home in your own
bedroom
punching movies with explosions I heard
of I that way of thinking because you
didn't grow up and living in like close
quarters with other people I've always
grown up with living with a lot of
people around like in apartments or when
I was really really little I lived in a
mobile home park and so there's just a
ton of people everywhere so I got used
to the like hearing life around me and
you grew up in single family home and
like a very spread out neighborhood so
because you know Texas everything spread
out so you didn't really have to deal
with other people's noises
I understand why it bugs you I never
actually never knew that was a thing I
never knew that you could be so been
barred by other people's noise until I
moved out on my own for college and
that's when I was like holy crap people
are noisy everywhere but then I thought
that was a college thing and I thought
okay once I like get out of college and
you know I live in a real neighborhood
it would stop but it didn't stop and I
just realized people were just noisy and
in close proximity when you share walls
it just comes to the territory which is
the biggest reason why I'm so excited to
move and finally have our own four walls
because the place that we're moving in
is really condensed like there's not a
lot of breathing room between homes but
it's definitely gonna be quieter and
like more secluded than what I'm used to
so I'm looking forward to it but I feel
like it's still not gonna meet up to
your your standard yeah we got to move
the Texas for that well we just gotta
figure out how to make more money or
that kind of living here in LA I know I
don't know it's attainable though you
have to be like millionaires I know
Elvia we're just talking to Isaac last
night and all that would you want to
move to Texas cuz I was like for the
money we're paying for this house in
Texas we could basically buy like a mini
mansion which is like kind of cool if
you think about it do we really need to
stay in California California housing it
really sucks not just California is just
LA and like San Francisco like the major
Oh true cities because yeah we couldn't
move out in the boonies in like Central
California and afford a really nice
house I'm pretty sure I don't know
but it's because it's so sought-after to
live here it's just crazy cousin mm-hmm
was oh you have anything to add to the
meeting oh we should where's your
harmonica
oh yeah harmonica I can't have the heck
do you open this fish in there and then
they can't cuz of my nails yeah so I've
been I bought a harmonica to learn how
to play it I haven't learned it yet but
you can just blow into it and have like
the most fun with the harmonica
sometimes good that sounds good too
regardless if you know how to play it or
not
it looks like all-in chords yeah and so
last night we were sitting here in the
kitchen floor for like and how are
everything with the cat he's gonna bite
me
[Music]
I've never seen him fight at you dirty
no it's like these likely recognized the
harmonica No
[Music]
you're like no not again but all last
night we're doing but they were going
crazy where they kept hitting our lady
true you keep playing oh my gosh he's
biting her instead of fighting you now
he's biting her oh they never do this
yeah harmonica makes them go crazy it's
like Audie audible catnip caddy
oh my god oh look at that dude like oh
dang he was biting her heart
geez he's gonna bite you now that my
uncle
he's going after my stuff I don't know
how to play anything there yet it sounds
really good
yeah you just doodlee doodlee doodlee
with your mouth shut the jnanis bonanza
and infamy on ma
give me Dickie let us do conmigo third
plane Savannah finally now this makes me
happy
you totalmente keep akhada knowing but
gets a sequin for me birthday
llamas lino hell masks and ammo you can
see em promoted room yes but of me then
you know
Oh cuz I've been bumping this song in my
car for like the past week but man like
there's just one part about that song
that my tongue always gets caught up in
caught up in and then right now I set it
pretty well so I'm pretty proud of
myself
alright so tip heads head out to a
meeting with her podcast group and
they're securing some business stuff she
says she's had a very business centric
day like Michael coming over taking care
of some stuff
yeah and that's left me to deal with the
office here at the house
alright so this room we have never fully
ever done it up to be like completed
like it's always been kind of like
half-ass you could take a look at the
room you'll see and it's just it's kind
of a temporary kind of fixture you know
what I mean I mean it's just got a blank
canvas here and then we kind of threw up
some stuff here to make them feel nicer
but I don't know there's just everything
here we just never really dealt with
this room and we've been here for four
years and I'm relieving and because we
didn't actually finish setting up this
room this room kind of became our
storage space as well there's a lot of
camera equipment here that I'd have no
idea whether or not actually Keith I
don't know if I want to keep this I
don't never use it so back in the day I
used to use Canon cameras a lot because
they were you know supposedly the best
dslr's
to have nowadays I use small cameras
such as this Sony camera you'll see the
difference
Canon Sony big size difference though
TIFF has asked me to clear out the
office and
[Music]
to rid of any equipment that I do not
want so camera stuff more camera stuff
tripods in here there's a lighting
equipment there's a microphone with the
hot filter drones yeah a lot of stuff I
don't use there's a lot of stuff in here
the hard part is not actually moving
them out and getting rid of them the
hard part is uh trying to figure out if
I want him or not and I tackle this
today now kind of dreading it took
forever for breakfast hiding behind the
laptop like I had more important things
to do and I'm just staring at this room
now like I should just go back to the
laptop
another camera this we go back to like
2009 now it's a 2010 I used to work
freelance video and photo before the
whole vlog stuff popped off even before
JK popped off cuz with JK we had a 5d
for JK we used to shoot all their skits
on the Canon 5d but the 7d though it was
more for my personal freelance work man
it's a little sentimental like now that
I'm staring at it with the intention of
possibly getting rid of this thing I
don't know if I want to get rid of it
this is my baby back then saved up a lot
of money to get this guy but this is a
first generation maybe second generation
7d it's not the greatest camera anymore
I don't know and I got this guy which is
the sony a6300
so it's not even the 6500 is this is
definitely an older one too we got this
guy this is the I already forgot the
name of this guy it's like having
multiple kids and not remember 80 kids
names
this is an 8 X 53 we call this the dad
cam all right so I've assembled I
finally found all the cameras and
assemble them in the order of how I got
them in the history of my my use of
cameras start off with that 70 like I
said earlier
and then expanded to a seventy do you
have a secondary camera but then after
the skit making documentary filming
photography days I really simplified and
went to a much smaller camera and this
was the first vlog camera that me and
tith had rx100 for after a while I got
tired of this I wanted to do more
cinematic stuff without hauling along
such a big camera like this like this is
just heavy but to get something better
than this we moved on to this guy which
I showed you guys earlier ultimately I
don't like I also need a camera that can
just zoom a lot you know like if I were
traveling at the time we're traveling a
lot I was like I want to get shots of
like really cool scenic stuff and that's
when the dad cam came in and this guy
this guy is known for zooming
capabilities got five different cameras
six cameras including the one I'm
holding right now GoPro and I think we
gotta make some cuts we gotta cut some
of these guys now can't bring all the
stuff with us because it means they got
mr. cameras but it's also the batteries
and the accessories and then all this
stuff is also accessories wanna stop
here the thing about our new house too
is that we don't have the same amount of
storage we have less storage at the new
house too so I don't know what to do
actually want to buy more cameras cool
even got this slider but I've never
really used all right so I put all my
cameras in here the drone that got
confiscated in Morocco but we got the
batteries and propellers in the bag
still here is the bigger drone that we
have and then we have a ring light that
we never use like none of this stuff
we've ever used
we have a lot of equipment make a movie
or something out of this stuff and then
I just realized I have a whole drawer
here with a lot of GoPro stuff and a
hero 3
I'm actually shooting on a what is this
hero seven in the hero too and these
were old I wonder how much these would
be worth if I were to sell it yes these
GoPros and gone whole bunch of
accessories and the good thing about
GoPro is that a lot of the stuff that is
universally like these attachments have
stayed universal for all GoPro models so
technically this stuff you could still
use the headache is deciding whether or
not to throw it away or keep it this
weekend is Valentine's Day and I didn't
know if we're gonna have a chance to
really celebrate Valentine's Day just me
and tip like being on romantic and stuff
and and I know I was like all right okay
so a longer Valentine's Day
yeah so Valentine's Day is on Friday
this year right and we're heading out
this comes out they're gonna be like
yeah
yes you're so late but love is forever
everything yeah so I want it to I don't
know have a little pre Valentine's Day
Valentine's a little bit oh I know you
like this and planning it and then and
then when you're like I guess and I'm
like oh no I was no yeah like I kind of
went all out like I'm like there's like
multiple pots and pans being used and
like if that wasn't trying to be like
Valentine's Day you'd be like a one-pot
kind of dinner you know that's way
easier right I ended up chopping up
stuff I'm like dang what do you do when
you cook thinking you don't chop things
up you don't have multiple things up
garlic powder is awesome onion powder is
awesome you know but then I used fresh
garlic today fresh ginger is that the
extra effort Majesty actually she ate it
you wait a second but you didn't use the
thing that we intentionally kept because
you said you were gonna use my fault my
fault oh did you actually get rid of it
because I knew you were gonna use what
this thing is left this is yeah this is
that garlic masher like the peeler thing
what the heck oh it's probably in there
it's over there somewhere you know what
it is yes but you know what it was
though that's not very sexy and I was
trying to be sexy yeah I was trying to
be like you know I'm gonna be a sexy
chef I don't want to be a you know a not
so sexy chef I guess I don't know this
is super sexy
is it really sexy it I just want you to
use me I just need to use it once and
once I use it at one time I'll remember
forever the sexiest utensil in all of
the kitchen lands okay all right it will
use it for the marinelli
no because it's okay for real though
like if you don't want to use it
get rid of it can I really new process
of purging and you you make me keep
things that you say you're gonna use and
they you don't know that's true no I
actually used it because I was getting
fed up with chopping up all that garlic
over there so putting it through that
grate that's in that tool would have
been an awesome good saved me like a
couple minutes right there then in there
mmm let's plate that spinach all right
we got to put it all together pass the
time go squeeze into your framing that's
a GoPro you're like you were you were in
favor Eddie nicely figure out my Herald
foodie ed oh I felt wacky for a second
excuse me as I feel lucky
I've never heard anyone go I felt the
wacky for a second and then own it like
you're all sexy and stuff
yeah that was really sick because you've
got all sultry with it anyway anyway
bone amputated oh well Yuriy a Taco Bell
there's a piece of fish over there yeah
I was like go ahead and get Isaac Taco
Bell I have plans tonight
what you got there I'm just making my
signature classic trademark
JC Tran gin drink I know I went through
it they on my language so we can start
eating cuz the food's won and that come
out and then I see him preparing we're
drinking tonight - I guess it is
Valentine's Day celebration there's no
good you should do them yeah we need we
need a citrus plate or something yeah so
I'm still drinking because like Nikki
says you drink til it's pink so cuz you
know they're trying to have a baby -
little race see let me read a rate of
pregnant yeah you're gonna beat Nikki oh
not everything is competitive not sure
but yes when she says that like
some women they continue to drink
alcohol until it shows that pink line
which means you're pregnant so drink
till it's pink it's on like okay I'll
take that advice I'll drink till the
thing do I say cheers Cheers oh it needs
eleven
[Music]